Hollywood saw an unprecedented 80 percent slump in box office revenues in North America in 2020.
That's almost a 40-year low according to historical data from Box Office Mojo.
Research firm Comscore's end-of-year report...
...has also stated that North American box offices...
...brought in just 2.2 billion dollars in 2020...
...compared to 11.4 billion dollars in 2019.
With movie theaters closed across the world due to lockdown measures,...
...studios were forced to delay release dates for scores of new films.
Some firms like AMC Entertainment were brought to the brink of bankruptcy.
Theaters are still yet to reopen...
...in the biggest US markets of Los Angeles and New York City.
Some 274 movies including blockbusters...
...like "No Time to Die," "Top Gun: Maverick" and the ninth "Fast and Furious" action film...
...were forced to move their release dates to 2021.
That left Sony Pictures cop caper "Bad Boys for Life" released in January last year...
...as the top-earning movie in North America for 2020 with 206 million dollars.
Thriller "Tenet" from Warner Brothers,...
...which hoped to tempt moviegoers back to theaters in the summer,...
...took just 58 million dollars in the U.S. and Canada.